foreign
brothers and sisters we're now in the
process of buying the carpets for the
first of its kind Masjid and our Center
in the whole country of Norway the cost
is around fifty thousand dollars would
you like to pitch in and share in the
enormous rewards for tens of thousands
of sajdas that will insha Allah be
performed on these carpets wouldn't it
be great to meet Allah with all of these
sajidas on your scale of good deeds and
if you're not following which reward I'm
referring to pay attention to this
Hadith the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said make lots of sujood for
you will not make a sahaja to Allah
accept that Allah raises your degree
because of it and removes a sin from you
because of it one single search that you
make will not only erase your sin but
also raise you a level in Jannah the
distance between the levels in Jannah is
like the distance between the Heaven and
the Earth and you will get this raise
for every single sister that you make
now imagine how many levels Allah will
raise you in Jannah when your sadaka
facilitates for tens of thousands of
sajdas
are you getting this
my dear brother or sister donate
generously and seek your your share of
the carpets before the 50k is all raised
this opportunity will only be outed for
a very short time if you miss it you
missed it so don't allow shaytan to
trick you by delaying it click the link
and make your donation now
foreign
[Music]